hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our match
between poor Charles Murphy and Samuel
Standish Bowdoin and in the previous
game a Morphy got a really bad position
straight from the straight from the
opening in this game it's Bowdoin who
gets a very bad position straight out of
the opening and then he's the one who
has to suffer now so it's a it's a very
interesting game I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy but before we check that out I
would just like to congratulate the
winners of yesterday's arenas so here
are the winners the winners of the
meadow arena are dev 90 chess hater and
Sadat one two three and the winners of
the agamotto friday arena are me he'll
2002 scarlet Foster and NAT Paul and we
are going to read every one from the top
ten so from the meadow arena like I said
the ninety chest hater and sat out one
two three guard 3 TTX 1a Lewis silletti
at nights two to Surya HR I got matter
to TMT and t200 and the diabetes so
those are the top ten and the top ten
from Agra matters Friday arena are like
we said me held 2002 Scarlett Foster
netball Bruno Popovich came in fourth
var at 45 Devon SH 29 Travis numata
Daniel C 87 jus collection analysis and
whole house in number 10 so there you
have it and now let's check out the game
at this time Morphy with the white
pieces and as you can see I fixed the
Murphy's middle name so it's no longer
miss misspelled opens with E for
boarding goes for e5 as he usually does
we have 93 Knight to c6 and here Morphy
goes for the Scotch with the d4 Bowdoin
grabs the pawn ECAD for Sandy for an
outburst of the C for the Scotch gambit
asking black do you wanna maybe try and
grab more material keep the pond or do
you want to go for development and of
course the Bowdoin goes for development
Bishop to c5 while defending the d4 pawn
and here more features castles boding
was for d6 he wants to develop his
light-square bishop as well
and now c3 by morphe his ideas he wants
to capture on d4 and create a very
strong center and if black wants black
can grab
another pawn and the Morphy will develop
the night so the best here is the
capture the pawn with black however born
once the also finish development so he
goes Knight to f6 and now C captures on
d4 we have better back the b6 and here
black has decent development however
white has a really massive center here
which of course morpheme knows how to
use Knight to c3 again just their
continuing development and Boden castles
with castles and now d5 asking Boden
what do you want to do here do you want
to go Knights the e5 where I can capture
your knight maybe go king h1 next and
then I will have the path open to go f4
would my pawn do you want to go Knight
to e7 maybe ship tonight over 2 G 6 or
the move that bottom plate Knights the
a5 which is which is the worst idea and
it's one of the reasons he gets a
terrible position straight out of the
opening more if you just move the bishop
bishop d3 and it is as a move 10 that
this position has never been reached
again and the problem is the knight has
no squares to retreat and b4 will
capture the night if more he gets before
in this Knight is doomed so of course
the Bowden has to prevent this he or he
goes for c5 but now okay you don't lose
the night but the night is still
stranded there the bishop and b6
prevents the point from being pushed to
be six so you cannot hide the Hydra
Knight and b7 and you will you will be
able to do it at some point you have to
go Bishop c7 b6 may be night here and
then well the night still can't go
anywhere but it's at least not very
vulnerable so morphic continues
development we have Bishop to g5 just
normal rapid development h6 and Bishop
to h4 now and now Boden also gets his
developing move with the light square
bishop so Bishop g4 pins the knight h3
and now Bishop to h5 but more fee is not
afraid to open up the position with the
g4 so he messes up the the the King's
defenses for a little bit but with good
cause
Bishop to g6 and now Queen to d2 he's
saying okay my eforp own is nicely
defended I'm bringing this rook over to
e1 and with this knife stranded on a 5
it's as if black is down a piece so rook
to e8 attacking the pawn 3
and no more features defense that rook
81 and now finally Bishop the c7
grabbing more control of the e5 square
but also may be preparing h6 b5
that's not b5 maybe you can get to
denied back into the game via the b7
square however morphe gets a very very
nice a fine idea if you will
Knight the b5 he puts pressure on the
bishop here and also there's a problem
because because of the pin here on the
knight so the Queen might be overloaded
and here you can play a lot of things
but probably dish up the b8 or Bishop to
b6 is the way to go it's not an easy
move to make but you don't want to have
this a constant pressure from the knight
on the bishop
however bottom plate king - h7 here and
we reach the position from the thumbnail
now this move loses the game terribly
there are various ways you can you can
proceed from here however there is one
that completely just crushes blacks so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this idea while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
unsporting well pretty much everything
there's a lot the spot here and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show it's 'if I've more people a bishop
captures an f6 it's a different idea but
still a good one
there's also knife chapters on c7 and
then going 'if I've but just 'if I've is
is definitely the way to go now here you
have a lot of problems the knight is
under attack of course the knight cannot
move as you lose the Queen if you go for
the bishop first then just captures
captures with check and after the King
moves or you play g6 then you just pick
up the knight and your upper piece so of
course completely winning and another
thing
after you capture on e5 which is the
only thing you can do if you don't want
to lose the game right away then comes
Knight captures and c7 Queen captures
and d6
this is the point and now of course the
Queen cannot capture the point because
Bishop captures and g6 with check and
after pawn or King recaptures you will
just grab the Queen and white is up a
queen so after this d6 move you have to
move the Queen but the
the story doesn't just end here after
Queen to d8 now you get night captures
on e5 and again there's nothing to do
for black here
the Queen still has to keep an eye on
the night here there are the this night
still cannot move this spawn is still
not available of course due to the ship
captures on g6 so pretty much whatever
you play here let's say Bishop captures
on d3 first you get night captures on f7
attacks the Queen and after the Queen
moves then finally Queen captures and d3
with check g6 and now the crushing
Bishop captures on f6 Queen captures on
f7 and now after this trade on e8
captures and captures at d7 ends the
game so it's just it's a long variation
but everything is forced so there's not
much black can do about anything here
you either allow the queening and then
you have to give up a whole rook or you
capture the bishop and then why just
gets another Queen and of course
completely winning so this was in the
position this ePHI move however morphe
went for a different idea he first
played Bishop captures on f6 or not
allowing Queen captures because black
loses the night so G captures on f6
Bowdoin has to recapture this way now
Knight characters and c7 Queen captures
and Queen to c3 now Queen to c3 with a
deadly threat this is one more if you
found otherwise he probably would have
gone for the e5 idea if he had studied
the position a little bit longer
attacking f6 also putting pressure on
the knight what the real threat is just
before winning the night because black
will not be able to recapture since the
Queen is hanging so Bowdoin has to go
back Queen to d8 and it's a pretty much
as usual if morphe spent a little more
time he would have found e5 and he would
probably end the game on the spot but
more if he didn't think all that much of
Bowden I mean he thought he was a decent
player but of course not not on the same
level as morphe and more if he never
wanted to take more than a few minutes
on the move very rarely taking a few
minutes on the move
pretty much or almost always moving
instantly so of course sometimes you
will miss a stronger continuation so
here Knight to h4 and a b6 now finally
defending this night and not the knife
can get back into the game even though
even from b7 you don't really have any
squares you have to move the Queen like
even if you even if you get the knight
over here you still have you still don't
have any squares because this point and
the point on f7 prevent the knight from
entering the game so this Knight is
doomed for the rest of the game so we
have f4 by morphing now putting a lot of
pressure on on blacks King side we have
King the g7 getting out of this diagonal
but just Knight captures and g 6f
captures and finally five and here you
have a problem of course you don't want
to open up the position as more physics
are fully operational here for example
if you try something like characters
captures and captures you just get
captures and now all sorts of nasty
discoveries are possible so you might
want to move the king but now rook f6 is
deadly really a fun move point is of
course you want to capture on g6 but if
Queen captures then rook captures here
with Czech and if you don't want to lose
the Queen you don't have time to capture
the rook you have to defend the Queen
somehow but then just captures captures
and captures and you are up a whole rook
so of course a completely unplayable so
here Bohdan wind looked the c8 instead
at some point he might want to push c4
and he just has to wait and see what
morph you will do but now Bishop to be
one of course morphine out wants the
grab hold of this diagonal put the Queen
in front of the bishop and go for
checkmate
so King f7 borden tries to hide the King
maybe run away over to the Queen side
but II six check now and now it doesn't
really matter what you do if King here
then g5 will be very very strong choking
back to g7 but now again Queen d3 going
for this g6 pawn and that there is no
move other than f5 you have to block
this somehow so f5g captures on f5 and
now Queen to f6 but more he says that's
not really anything so just GF
characters and g6
bowden grabs the b2 pawn but now f5 and
now if f6 comes is just game over
so Queen blocks f6 and this is just very
sad when you have a queen blocking
3-connected passed pawns that's that's
very sad but you know it is what it is
and now Murphy doesn't what he does best
in situations like this he finds an
instant when he just pushes e7 preparing
rook to e6 fouled by pushing the pawn to
f6 and that's game over and the problem
is of course you cannot capture this
because after characters and captures f6
wins the Queen there's no way in no way
to do anything here so Boden tried c4 it
attacks the Queen and also this is now a
passed pawn so of course you want to
push it but the Queen to g3 by Murphy
still the idea is the same rookie 6
followed by f6 so c3 there's no way to
prevent this you still cannot capture on
e7 and now of course rooked ecigs
kicking away the Queen Queen the d4
width check and now Queen to have two
more few offers the Queen trade and of
course if Queen trade happens doesn't
really change anything f6 is coming and
it's game over
and also you guarded the C 2 square so
it's not a problem
so after Queen F 2 Queen captures and d5
was played but now it's actually mating
4 so feel free to pause the video and
try to calculate out the mating for idea
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the mating 4
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course you know
you know what it is it's f6 wait check
so the best regards the g6 Ponder's
nothing to be done here you have to go
back doesn't matter King h8 Rho gh King
h8 is more resilient but now g7 check of
course you cannot come to h6 h7 so King
g8 f7 check and after King captures on
g7 well you could play a lot of moves to
win the game here we are of course
looking for checkmate and that Queen to
f6 and this is not of course checkmate
so really wild game morphe retaliates in
great style and Bowden was the one who
was suffering for the entire game and as
you can see this Knight is not played on
a 5 for good reason and that position
has has never been reached again for
very good reasons as this night even if
you bring it back into the game there's
still no way for this night to enter the
game so a terrible square for the knight
don't ever
that in positions like this of course
sir
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Richard Hennessy
Yahoo nom Philip triking a Lucca Pete
and JP TB for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
JP TB actually graduated from MIT this
week so congratulations on that man a
good job and also it was his birthday so
I wish you all the best as well so once
again as usual you can check to my
previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Murphy saga we're gonna
check up on POC champs championship
we're gonna check up on clutch just that
that's starting today so a lot of things
happening and we have our work cut out
for us and also once again
congratulations to the winner of both
arenas thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day